This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It is the most reviled form of contemporary architecture. There is. A McMansion is an oversized house, usually over 3000 square feet, that doesn't really interact with its environment, whether that's the houses around it, or if it's built in the middle of nowhere, that environment as well. This is Kate Wagner, creator of the blog of McMansion Hell, where she helps readers like me understand what is and isn't a McMansion, and why we hate them.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。这是当代建筑中最受诟病的建筑形式。没错。麦克豪宅是一种超大尺度的住宅，通常超过3000平方英尺，它与周围环境完全没有互动，无论是周围的房子，还是如果它建在荒郊野岭，与那个环境也是如此。这位是凯特·瓦格纳，麦克豪宅地狱博客的创立者，她在这里帮助像我这样的读者了解什么是麦克豪宅，什么不是，以及为什么我们讨厌它们。
The main signs of a McMansion are that they're built cheaply with very cheap materials, new materials rarely ever traditional materials. As you can tell by the name of the blog and by her general demeanor, Kate Wagner hates the Magmánchen. They're built without any sort of consideration for the grammar of design. Since the creation of this show, I've used the word architecture in the most tenuous and metaphorical of ways, but according to Kate, the Mag McMansion may not even qualify as architecture at all. There's no real architecture in the McMansion, and it's two ostentations to be considered folk architecture.
麦克豪宅的主要标志是它们建造低成本，使用非常廉价的材料，新材料很少用到传统的材料。正如你从博客的名字和她的一般举止所看出的那样，凯特·瓦格纳讨厌麦克豪宅。它们的建造完全不考虑设计语法。自从这个节目开播以来，我一直以最微弱、最隐喻的方式使用“建筑”这个词，但据凯特所说，麦克豪宅可能根本不配被称为建筑。麦克豪宅中没有真正的建筑，它太过炫耀，不能被视为民间建筑。
They have no architectural commentary. All they do is represent sort of an ideal of wealth. But it's more an image of wealth rather than wealth itself. It's very much meant to convey that one message that I have a lot of money and a lot of space. And I am putting it in this house that is so tall and so massive that you feel intimidated by it just as you should feel intimidated by my apparent wealth. That single purpose, to convey wealth, That single purpose to convey wealth, steam roles, every other potential design principle, like symmetry, or logic, history, or beauty. Yeah, who cares if you have a big house?
它们没有任何建筑评论。它们所做的只是代表了一种财富的理想。但这更多的是财富的形象，而不是财富本身。它非常明确地传达了一个信息：我有很多钱，也有很多空间。我把它放进这栋如此高大宏伟的房子里，让你对它感到畏惧，就像你应该对我的表面财富感到畏惧一样。那个单一的目的，即传达财富，那个单一的目的即传达财富，碾压了所有其他潜在的设计原则，比如对称、逻辑、历史或美感。是的，谁会在乎你是不是有一栋大房子呢？
If it's like so ugly, I don't want to look at it. Kate believes the source of this ugliness stems from the combination of mass production and customization. During the 90s and 2000s, thanks to easy access to a lot of money through bad mortgages pushed on the American people, the tastes of the new home buyer ran to the extreme. The standard models of these mass produced homes reflected that, but of grand entrances and granite countertops and stainless steel appliance was weren't nice enough. Many new home manufacturers allowed for customizations that brought the opulence to the next level. So they'll combine the two
如果它长得这么丑，我才不想看它。凯特认为这种丑陋的根源在于大批量生产和个性化的结合。在上世纪90年代和2100年代，由于通过推销给美国人民的不良抵押贷款轻而易举地获得了大量资金，新购房者的品味走向了极端。这些量产房屋的标准型号反映了这一点，但宏伟的入口、花岗岩台面和不锈钢家电还不够好。许多新住宅制造商允许进行个性化定制，将奢华提升到了一个新的水平。所以他们会把两者结合起来
an already designed prototype with sort of a custom home, which can end up in some pretty wild looking results. So they're designed and customized from the inside out and it makes the outside big and weird and lumpy. Because somebody wanted cathedral ceilings in their bathroom, which is obviously a necessity. The first victim in the design from the inside out process is the roof. Make-manchin roofs are a mess. The roof is sort of the number one way to tell a make-manchin from a mansion
一个已经设计好的原型加一点定制住宅，这最终可能会带来一些非常疯狂的结果。所以它们是从里到外设计和定制的，这使得外部看起来又大、又怪、又臃肿。因为有人在他们的浴室里想要大教堂式的天花板，这显然是一个必需品。从内到外设计过程中的第一个牺牲品是屋顶。麦克豪宅的屋顶简直是一团糟。屋顶可以说是区分麦克豪宅和普通豪宅的第一种方法
and that the roof kind of makes no sense. It's got various pitches, which is how it's sort of steep. The roof is, and it's got many different shapes, many different heights, many different angles. Like a gable roof, with a hip to roof, the pyramidal roof, you don't really need to know what these look like, but just no, they're not usually all together. They're really just there to put a hat on a ridiculously crafted house. But the kuda grass of the McManshin roof is a feature that Kate has dubbed the McManshin nub. The McManshin nub is where you'll see like a roof line that is relatively organized and
而且屋顶感觉毫无逻辑。它有各种各样的坡度，也就是屋顶陡峭的程度，并且它有许多不同的形状、许多不同的高度、许多不同的角度。比如双坡屋顶与四坡屋顶、金字塔形屋顶的结合，你其实不需要知道这些长什么样，但只要知道，它们通常不会全部挤在一起。它们真的只是给一个荒谬建造的房子戴上一顶帽子而已。但麦克豪宅屋顶的点睛之笔，是一个被凯特称为“麦克豪宅凸起”的特征。麦克豪宅凸起是指你会看到一条相对有组织、规整的屋顶线，然后
then you'll just have like this bump at the top because somebody had to have some feature and they just like couldn't fit it in linearly. Usually it's like either stored space or like someone wanted some ridiculous ceilings or ceiling feature. So they just have this like nub at the top. So it's like a hat to a hat if you will. According to Kate another hallmark of the McMansion is the two story entrance. You walk into a house brokers and marketers and hosts of house flipping TV shows. So to have a big entryway, you should probably have a pretty big door. And then on top of that really big door, there's a really big window. Sometimes there's like three foot of useless space and then the really big door. And then on top of that really big door, there's a really big window. Sometimes there's like three foot of useless space and then the really big window. The window usually
接下来你就会看到顶部有一个隆起，因为某人必须拥有某种功能，而他们只是无法将其线性融入其中。通常要么是储藏空间，要么是有人想要一些荒谬的天花板或天花板特征。所以他们在顶部弄了这样一个隆起。所以可以说是帽子上又戴了一顶帽子，如果你愿意这么说的话。根据凯特的说法，麦克豪宅的另一个标志是两层楼高的入口。你走进一栋房子，房产经纪人、市场营销人员和房屋翻新真人秀的主持人都在那。因此，要有一个大的玄关，你可能应该有一个相当大的门。然后在那个真正的大门之上，是一个非常大的窗户。有时会有大约三英尺的无用空间，然后才是真正的大门。而在那个真正的大门之上，是一个非常大的窗户。有时会有大约三英尺的无用空间，然后才是真正的大门。这扇窗户通常
has a square bottom to match the top of the door and an arched top. That kind of window shape didn't even exist really before the McMansion. The McMansion invented that window. It's not only the window on top of the door that makes Kate and the avid readers of McManchine Hell cringe, it's all the windows. And I do mean all of the windows. There's usually more than three different shapes of windows. Of course, there are always thoughtful and interesting violations of any design guidelines, but generally Kate thinks the house should limit the front facade to two or fewer window shapes, while keeping a single window style across the entirety of a single story.
底部是正方形以配合门顶，顶部则是拱形。这种窗户形状在麦克豪宅出现之前甚至根本不存在。麦克豪宅发明了这种窗户。让凯特和“麦克豪宅地狱”的忠实读者感到难堪的，不仅是门上的那扇窗户，而是所有的窗户。我是说所有的窗户。通常有三种以上不同形状的窗户。当然，任何设计准则总有一些深思熟虑且有趣的违规之处，但总的来说，凯特认为房子应该把正立面的窗户形状限制在两种或以下，同时在单层建筑的整体上保持单一的窗户风格。
I get ridiculous houses in my inbox all the time, where there's like six different types of windows from six different architectural styles. It's sort of a garbled communication of sorts. You can't filter the signal from the noise, design-wise. And last but not least, you can't have a big, ostentatious house without columns. So the columns usually are either oversized or undersized. Or sometimes the columns are not columns at all. They're just column-shaped protrusions from the exterior wall. Basically a a column is created to sort of balance whatever it is that it's holding up. That's the point of columns is that they hold things up.
我的收件箱里经常收到一些荒谬的房子，里面有来自六种不同建筑风格的六种不同类型的窗户。这可以说是某种杂乱无章的交流。在设计方面，你无法从噪音中过滤出信号。最后但并非最不重要的一点，没有柱子的宏伟浮夸房子是不完整的。所以柱子通常要么过大，要么过小。或者有时柱子根本不是柱子。它们只是外墙上呈柱状的突起。基本上，创造柱子的目的是为了平衡它所支撑的任何东西。柱子的意义就在于它们支撑着东西。
I don't know, a lot of people seem to have not understood that in the last 30 years. But they actually are supposed to hold things up. And so if you have these really big columns and they're holding up the tiniest little pediment or portico, then it looks like pretty ridiculous. But the point is that you have the really big columns, so everyone knows that you're rich like a bank that also has really big columns. All right, so this kind of snarky criticism is fun at all.
我不知道，过去30年里似乎很多人都没有理解这一点。但它们实际上应该用来支撑东西。所以如果你有这些非常大的柱子，而它们支撑的却是一个极其微小的山形墙或门廊，那看起来就会非常荒谬。但重点是你要有非常大的柱子，这样每个人都知道你很有钱，就像一家同样拥有非常大柱子的银行一样。好了，这种尖酸刻薄的批评其实挺有趣的。
It's really fun for me, but there's a larger point to be made about the design of the McMansion. According to Kate, the age of the McMansion saw the shift of the house from a place that we live in, potentially for the rest of our lives, to an asset that we are decidedly not supposed to live in forever. People started designing their houses with the notion of selling them in mine. Real letters would advise, oh, I wouldn't buy or do this because the house isn't going to sell very well. So we sort of devised this culture where we thought about selling our houses before we even spent one night in them. Kate lays the blame for this mindset at the feet of HGTV and
对我来说真的很有趣，但关于麦克豪宅的设计，还有一个更宏大的观点要表达。据凯特所说，麦克豪宅时代见证了房屋性质的转变：从一个我们可能在其中度过余生的居住场所，变成了一项我们显然不打算永远居住的资产。人们开始带着出售的想法来设计他们的房子。房地产中介会建议，哦，我不会买这个或这样做，因为这房子会很难卖。所以我们设计出了一种文化，在我们在房子里甚至还没过夜之前，就已经开始考虑卖掉它了。凯特将这种心态归咎于HGTV和
similar channels. The excess and conformity of the McMansion was reinforced over and over again on home improvement and the house flipping TV shows because the House as object could always be improved. Not necessarily to make it better, but to make it sell. Home improvement channels would paint a house beige, and then you would see this ticker in the corner that says, oh, we just added $800 to the value of this house or something like that. They would come up with these crazy ways to quantify these sort of improvements that sort of caused people to go into these frenzies and that's why so many houses look the same is because
类似的频道。房屋装修和房屋翻新真人秀节目一遍又一遍地强化了麦克豪宅的过度与千篇一律，因为作为物体的房屋总是可以被改进。不一定是为了让它更好，而是为了让它好卖。房屋装修频道会把房子刷成米色，然后你就会在角落里看到一个滚动条，上面写着，哦，我们刚刚为这栋房子增加了800美元的价值诸如此类的信息。他们会想出这些疯狂的方法来量化这类改进，从而导致人们陷入这种疯狂状态，这就是为什么那么多房子看起来都一样，因为
This is what was told would make our house worth more Rather than what actually does make a house worth more which is structural changes Improving energy efficiency green upgrades things like, not like adding a certain color of paint. It's totally subjective. Older MacManchons built in the early 2000s are not proving to be a very good investment. Smaller houses are appreciating at a much faster rate than larger houses. But after a lull in the market following the housing crisis, builders are finding buyers for huge brand new homes again. According to CBS News, quote,
这就是被告知会让我们房子更值钱的东西，而不是真正让房子更值钱的东西——比如结构改变、提高能效、绿色升级之类的事情，而不是刷上某种颜色的油漆。这完全是主观的。建于2100年代初期的较老旧麦克豪宅并没有证明是一笔很好的投资。较小的房屋正在以比大房子快得多的速度升值。但在住房危机之后的市场低迷期过后，建筑商再次为巨大的全新住宅找到了买家。根据CBS新闻报道，引述
homes 4,000 square feet or larger saw a sharp jump in sales last year, rising 30% from the year earlier, end quote. It's safe to assume that all the bad design choices in the first round of McMatchans will continue on in this new generation, which is not good news if you enjoy the vibrancy of variability in the built world. A houses of differing styles sets another thing that gives us a sense of place. You can tell that you're somewhere else because all the houses are different, but the sort of sprawl aesthetic is that it's the same everywhere.
面积在4000平方英尺或更大的房屋去年的销售额出现了大幅飙升，比前一年增长了30%，引述结束。可以肯定的是，第一轮麦克豪宅中的所有糟糕设计选择将在新一代中延续下去，如果你喜欢建筑世界中多样性的活力，这可不是什么好消息。风格各异的房屋为我们提供了另一种场所感。你可以看出你在别的地方，因为所有的房子都不一样，但蔓延美学的特点是它在任何地方都一样。
And houses and styles didn't evolve through a planning committee. They evolved through a combination of popular taste and place. Like that's why you'll see like poebo style architecture in the west, but you're not going to see it in Kerry North Carolina. It's just one of those things that gives you a context of where you are and that the built environment has everything to do with place as the natural environment does. Embedded in the pages of McMaster and Hell are lessons in consumerism and materialism, but fundamentally Kate Wagner picks apart these crimes against architecture in hilarious
房屋和风格并不是通过规划委员会演变而来的。它们是通过大众品味和地点的结合演变而来的。就像这就是为什么你在西部会看到普韦布洛风格的建筑，但在北卡罗来纳州的卡 Cary 你不会看到它。这只是赋予你身处何地背景的事情之一，人工建筑环境与自然环境一样，与地点有着密不可分的联系。隐藏在《麦克豪宅地狱》网页中的是关于消费主义和物质主义的教训，但从根本上说，凯特·瓦格纳以欢快
and excruciating detail to teach us the fundamentals of architecture in a new way. Using humor to educate people about the world around them is sort of a great way to get people involved in the sort of greater design, community. Most people, what they learned about architecture in school is they learn like the Greek orders and it's like, oh, this is the ionic column. Yes, this is the flying buttress, everyone's knickers, and it's really dry. People really don't care. I firmly believe that people do care. Even if we don't know why, even if we don't know how to articulate it,
和极其详尽的细节剖析了这些对建筑的犯罪行为，以一种崭新的方式教给我们建筑的基本原理。利用幽默来教育人们了解周围的世界，是让人们参与到更广泛的设计社区中的绝佳方式。大多数人在学校里学到的关于建筑的知识，都是关于希腊柱式的，就像，哦，这是爱奥尼柱式。是的，这是飞扶壁，所有人都惊掉下巴，而且这非常枯燥。人们其实并不在乎。我坚信人们是在乎的。即使我们不知道为什么，即使我们不知道如何表达，
we feel the effects of bad design, whether we consciously notice it or not. So now people can say, now I know why I hate that house. Thank you. Now it's like, wow, actually none of these windows match. I hate that. And it's empowering people to have opinions
我们都能感受到糟糕设计带来的影响，无论我们是否有意注意到它。所以现在人们可以说了，现在我知道我为什么讨厌那座房子了。谢谢。现在感觉就像，哇，实际上这些窗户根本没有一个是对齐的。我讨厌这样。这赋予了人们对以下事物发表意见的赋能
about the built environment, which they have mostly been served through like a marketing or materialistic lens, rather than from a design standpoint. And as I've learned with pointing out the bad design of city flags, once you get people to notice bad design, your annoyance spreads like a virus. I get a lot of emails, like a lot of messages that say like, before I read this blog, I didn't give two crafts about architecture. And now I start to notice these
关于建筑环境，这些环境过去主要是通过营销或物质主义的镜头呈现给他们的，而不是从设计的角度。正如我在指出城市旗标的糟糕设计时所了解到的那样，一旦你让人们注意到糟糕的设计，你的烦恼就会像病毒一样蔓延。我收到很多电子邮件，比如很多信息说，在我读这个博客之前，我对建筑一点也不关心。现在我开始注意到这些
things on all of the buildings I passed by. And that makes me so happy because now other people have to suffer through what I have suffered for years and years and years. And we will all suffer together, with our bad houses, and our ugly flags, and doors that you don't know whether to push or pull. And our light switches, you never remember which light they go to even though you've lived in the house for 20 freaking years. And our terrible currency, and our ugly passports, and our comic sands, and our public bench armrests, and our bogus expiration dates, and our confusing ballots.
我路过的所有建筑物上都有这些东西。这让我太高兴了，因为现在其他人也必须经历我多年来一直经受的痛苦。我们将和我们的劣质房子、丑陋的旗帜、分不清是该推还是拉的门一起受苦。还有我们的电灯开关，明明在这个房子里住了整整20年，你却永远记不住它们控制哪盏灯。还有我们糟糕的货币、丑陋的护士、漫画无衬线字体（Comic Sans）、公共长椅的扶手、虚假的过期日期，以及令人困惑的选票。
That one we really need to fix, like soon. 99% invisible is Katie Mingle, Kurt Coles that, to refuse stuff, Sam Greenspan, Avery Troll from the Emmett Fitzgerald, Teraren Mazza, Delaney Hall, and me Roman Mars. All the music this week was composed by Sean Rial. We are a project of 91.7 KLW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. So last week I presented at the Frontiers Conference organized by the White House. President Obama was there and it was a very cool event.
那张选票我们真的需要修复，比如快点。99%隐形由凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特达特、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特罗尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰伦·马扎、德兰尼·霍尔以及我罗曼·马斯共同制作。本周的所有音乐均由肖恩·里亚尔创作。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街。所以上周我在白宫组织的“前沿会议”上做了演讲。奥巴马总统也在那里，这是一个非常酷的活动。
I volunteered my time and I got myself out there and as a thank you for my effort, the White House organizer gave me a presidential challenge coin, which as you can imagine, was a very big deal to me. The 99% invisible challenge coins are all gone, but for this year, for the fundraiser, we decided to design new radio-topia challenge coins to give to all the people who've stayed with us as regular donors for the last year as a token of our appreciation and offer them to new backers who want to get on board and keep our show going strong. Having one of these coins means that you're committed to radio topia being the home of independent producer-driven podcasts and when you challenge me with a coin, that means
我贡献了我的时间，展现了自己，作为对我努力的感谢，白宫组织者给了我一枚总统挑战币，你可以想象，这对我很重要。99%隐形的挑战币已经全都没有了，但今年为了筹款活动，我们决定设计新的“无线电托邦（Radiotopia）”挑战币，作为感谢送给所有在过去一年里一直作为我们的常规捐赠者支持我们的朋友，并将其提供给想要加入并让我们的节目保持强劲发展的新支持者。拥有其中一枚币意味着你承诺让无线电托邦成为独立制作人驱动播客的家，当你用一枚币向我发起挑战时，这意味着
you're part of a family of people that makes this all possible. Plus, the new coin just looks awesome. I can't wait to get one myself. Go to radiotopia.fm to become a coin carrying radio topian. If we add 5,000 donations to the rolls, fresh books who make cloud accounting software, particularly designed for independent creative people like me, will donate $40,000.
你是让这一切成为可能的人类大家庭的一员。另外，新币看起来太棒了。我自己都迫不及待想拥有一个了。前往radiotopia.fm成为一名持有挑战币的无线电托邦人。如果我们增加5000笔捐款，“Freshbooks”（制作专为像我这样的独立创意人士设计的云端会计软件的公司）将捐赠40000美元。
But we need you to make that challenge. And I mean you. Go to radiotopio.fm. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram, and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio to P.I.
但我们需要你来发起挑战。我说得就是你。前往radiotopio.fm。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解关于这个故事的更多信息，包括精彩的图片和链接，并收听99%隐形的所有单集，你必须访问99pi.org。Radio to P.I.
From P.R.X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。